drunk
adam and eve.com with all the bad news
about prices these days skyrocketing wow
okay at the gas station and everywhere
else it's nice to know that adam and eve
is still offering the very best deal not
skyrocketing which is good for your
pockets at adamandeve.com get 50 percent
off plus free shipping that is a lot of
percentage 50 off an adventurous new toy
or anything you want anything else you
want there on their site uh our product
listeners will get 50 off almost any
item just use the code lifeline at
checkout and you will get 50
off and free shipping and free shipping
huge deal doesn't matter what you choose
all will be packaged and sent discreetly
for free it won't make a whole big
production out of it you'll get your
thing that you ordered and it'll be very
very
hush-hush not only will you save money
on gas movies and date night dinners out
but this is the item that will continue
to save you money deliver tons of fun
and satisfaction and you can keep keep
keeping on using it yeah so go to
adamandeve.com select any one item use
code lifeline
i n l-i-f-e-l-i-n-e and this is an
exclusive offer specific to this podcast
so be sure to support our show and use
this code lifeline to get you not just
the 50 off but also the 100
free shipping code lifeline go to
adamandeve.com right now adamandeve.com
right now
lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or licensed professional
[Music]
do it live
so we always
have
robots robots we always have this we do
this podcast we've been doing it we're
almost done
wow [ __ ] up so 20 episodes in
and
uh look man
yeah you have
often have too many drinks this is
really really where you jump the shark
there's too many [ __ ] drinks on the
table it's good because i don't have to
get up if i want a drink there's milk on
the table when's the last time you
[ __ ] drank a glass of milk
years okay so you don't need milk you've
also it's [ __ ] i don't know two
percent i don't even use only my coffee
i don't milk usually i don't use my
coffee so i'll put the milk down yeah
and we'll get rid of a lot of these
people can't see my coffee which i also
have you know what they can see what's
up we told you we promised and it's true
look at this we've got the lifeline
merch finally out if you are a fan of
the show if you support the show you
know the spin move mentality we got the
hoodie here we got the t-shirt here we
want to show you the back that's where
we hung it up right here this is what
the back of the hoodie looks like check
it out matt's
well we they already see the back of the
hoodie that's the whole reason why we
did this okay but they can't hear you
now right because of your time
when it's on you it's different but this
is why i did it i pulled the muscle
so uh and then we got these two we got
the hoodie version and the uh let's try
to not have this mess up the
actual paint
okay there we go and we're good but also
show them the back of your gun i'm gonna
show them okay we'll do it faster um so
we have that we have the thing and then
we have this this is my favorite though
dude that might be my favorite too look
how sick that is
that's [ __ ] bout about it it's cool
dude and it's so hot in the studio so
we'll probably end up taking these off
yeah it's actually so hot on youtube you
can show how nice it is before i do that
yeah we yeah and it is where do you get
them where do we get them
mine
lifeline merch.com lifeline merch you
can find it out on my instagram bio and
all that stuff you can go in there but
you go find it find it you know what how
about this find it all right find it if
you want it so bad [ __ ] fine lifeline
we're here and uh so that's what's up
and we're excited about it it's been a
long process we wanted to get the
designs down uh because we didn't want
it to just be some shitty shinty [ __ ]
and uh i'll tell you what usually when
you know i'm a part of designing any
kind of merch i
i land on the thing that
we agree on and then
i'm stoked about it and then it comes
and it's like
80 as good as i thought it would be this
is like
exceeds my expectations here's the [ __ ]
looks good and the reason why it took so
long is because matt wasn't sure the
whole time and then when we [ __ ]
delivered i said matt just trust me we
did it and now [ __ ]
okay but i like to think the way i did
it right it
had us making sure that it was going to
be great all right well we're chilling
we're having a good time here uh we're
downtown la that's where we do it and we
were in downtown l.a and i stopped to
get a [ __ ] coffee bean and teal if
you know how i do and um
i uh i got down to the i got down to the
coffee bean tea leaf i saw about three
people on the street and when i saw them
they all said hi to me and that's very
weird and the only thing i know about
that so here's the thing if somebody
says hi to you you're walking down the
street anywhere yeah then nice people
right if you're downtown l.a that's how
you know they're crazy yeah i mean
everybody's crazy downtown late night no
but it's sad though it's actually sad
it's definitely sad it's also it's just
[ __ ] it's never ending so like
you get sort of jaded by it anybody that
asks you for anything you're just like
nah
nah right no whereas normally you i at
least i am open to giving people [ __ ]
but every [ __ ] half block
somebody's coming up asking me for
something it's usually an autograph
usually no picture with me in it no no
usually [ __ ] whatever a kiss on the
forehead wow the the [ __ ] pope so
yeah i'm the pope speak of the pope i've
been watching the tudors
[Applause]
why are you clapping about you watching
i've been watching the tutors i saw a
[ __ ] five episodes in two nights and
how is it does kristen like it she
watched the beginning of the first
episode and then was on tick tock and
then went to bed and then the second
night she didn't want to do it because
she went to bed
no i'm pissed dude but it's all good i
did [ __ ] spin move back downstairs
watch the whole thing and i'm down
[ __ ] watch it and watch it instead of
her watch it with her i'll watch it with
a friend
wow you watch the tutors with a friend
yeah dude
you have mental problems well no it's
good you know why it's good and i'll
tell you this okay here's the deal i get
it's not
very
it's not as thought-provoking as it as a
show like that should be okay but i i
wondered why
it's it's it's just it's watchable first
of all like jonathan is it jonathan
reese and rhys myers yeah he is so
obviously not henry viii it's
unbelievable and i heard that he was
like i'm going to do the part and then
wouldn't put on the fat suit and
wouldn't dye his hair oh dude i hate
this which sucks but also it's like
who cares if they look like the people
in history i guess it adds to it you
agree no i fully agree oh you do fully
agree that it doesn't matter what they
look like when people get so caught up
in like with rey with jamie foxx and i
was like he looks just like him anthony
hopkins and nixon he looks just like who
gives a [ __ ] they're acting i know me i
know i spend your [ __ ] disbelief
exactly exactly let me know the other
thing i hate right now
i'm not a crook the other thing i hate
though is the is when
when there's like a let's say it's an uh
an american movie but it takes place in
france
and all the american or english actors
do a [ __ ] french accent 100 agree
with that a hundred percent just either
do it in french or don't
[ __ ] bother do it in french honestly
or
honestly no accent yeah or even just
pick an accent i don't give a [ __ ] it's
better than just they didn't speak in
french accents they speak they spoke in
french be a [ __ ] boston dude yeah and
be like oh i think that the tiger got
him yeah that would be good yeah like in
[ __ ] gladiator if it was just like
some dude that was just like oh from
fargo right yeah that'd be good too oh
oh
oh one of the gladiators died so any
accent as long as it's not the place
where they're actually like taking place
yeah like do like be
joaquin phoenix and go like this when
when you want to kill a guy do that okay
do that in this
oh no oh he died eh right okay oh no
it's like an armenian person
so i watch the tudors and the only
reason why i watch that show is because
eric griffin keeps telling me okay about
this scene
where there's a guy whose job it is to
catch how do we not get [ __ ] age
restricted for this or demonetized to
catch the king's
um
spillage when he uh
yeah and he just sits there with a when
he does the kumjabi thing and he goes
like this and then over he goes like
this and he goes like this and folds it
and he leaves that's his whole role
that's his job worst role worst acting
real role of all time you know
oh yeah i was in the tudors i played uh
jonathan rhys myers his [ __ ] kumjabi
collector and
come jobby dude it was a great
experience uh yeah oh wow dude that's
amazing just just this
and it shows it shows you it like one
one it shows one thing where you play
the neighbor and according to jim right
and then one thing where you're just
like and then a doritos commercial and
jonathan
and then jennison reese myers was like
ha ha and you're just like thank you
[ __ ] quarterback thank you sir and
the next thing is the doritos commercial
where the bag is like spitting and [ __ ]
and you catch it yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh wow best [ __ ]
acting reel of all time yeah so um
so yeah i'm watching the tutors and i'm
[ __ ] hell into it dude i mean i'm
into it i can't believe you're into that
you're always in the [ __ ] that's like
really dumb for dumb people i know but i
but
i think that it's actually like because
here's the thing when television or
movies try to be too smart i'm [ __ ]
out that's for dumb people i think i
think this is a better version of game
of thrones there i said it
but it's not similar the tudors is based
in a true story in it there's no dragons
and [ __ ] i know that's why why are you
comparing them because it is the same
kind of they walk they walk the same and
they talk the same and [ __ ] okay and
they yell at the same times okay how
many of us everyone's [ __ ] each other
how many episodes of game of thrones
have you seen
three seasons really yep guess how many
dragons i've seen you just like won you
just dropped a [ __ ] bomb on yeah
bombs man didn't expect that so um
well by the way i was walking downtown
before we get into it i was walking
downtown just today and another guy one
of the guys who said hi another dude
walked by me and he was walking by and i
was playing the parking meter and he
looked at me and he just he looks at me
and he says i'm innocent and kept
walking
that reminds me when i used to live in
new york i was chilling at [ __ ]
washington square park
and i was just reading a book
guy comes up to me he's like kind of
nervous do you know where this is going
no i think he knows this story though
yeah yeah uh he walks up to me and he's
like
he's just like uh hey and he's kind of
like nervous see me he goes hey and he
kind of stumbles on his words and then
he stops stumbling on his words and he
finally says i have aids oh yeah and i
was just like oh
that's not a good icebreaker you know
so i have aids can i have some change
all good that you have aids but don't
leave what are you trying to do so i
have aids i was wondering if you have a
representation i'm an agent of hollywood
um no i think you just if i remember
correctly i mean that kind of is all i
remember
but uh i think he wanted uh and we dated
for a few months and uh
how was that yeah so all right so you
have too many drinks and i'm dripped out
and gold and it's all good dude
right i know so
um all right let's do you want to get
into the show or what sure we'll get
into the show go to get your lifeline
merch we got it all we wore it and we
you saw it with these
mentality uh coffee too all right cool
matt comfy a reggae artist
hey uh luke here from the uk i love the
podcast and chris i love your podcast as
well
uh so i just wanted a bit of advice on
me and my partner we're
emigrating to australia in a couple
months but in the meantime
we're moving back into my parents and
lived with my sister and
i just wanted a bit of advice really you
know how we carry on doing the
horizontal yeah with them two in the
house there was one time when i first
brought my partner back um i left my
belt on the floor and i had to make up
some story
my mom fell for it because you know your
boy's got acting in his corner he looks
like nice
so yeah just a bit of advice on
how we keep it uh
keep it moving in the old parents thanks
guys david brent um
well
i think
jesus man save the blasting for when
your parents are gone if possible and if
you can't if they don't leave if there's
no blastage possible
when you if there's no passage possible
when they're gone right a professor i
think that what you need to do is tr is
is have the
quiet blastage where it's like you kind
of just like wow
tight-lipped making sure it's just like
the efforts are contained
and you're just doing it slow you're not
banging the bed against the wall right
because that's a big one you're trying
to do the quiet blast out from the wall
yeah from the middle of the room yeah
only a [ __ ] in the middle of the room
yeah yeah exactly if that's the floor
that's a floor yeah if it's the ottoman
that's the ottoman and don't leave your
belt on the ground so here we have save
the blastage right here we've saved the
batches for when the parents are gone if
the parents are here we're gonna do
quiet blastage worst professor of all
time jet propulsion laboratories
uh yeah dude i think that um
there's a lot of crazy cool places to do
blastage though you could do car blasted
you could do [ __ ] yeah actually maybe
in a motel are there motels in britain i
don't know try to do the blessed outside
the house if they're always at the house
you know yeah illegal but yeah or or
watch like if you have a tv in your own
room watch it real loud right right but
don't watch sex scenes because then
it'll sound like it's you know like
watch like [ __ ] saving private ryan
you know wow
sad blastage right right right right
you're the same guy that he shot him in
the first place
wait you're kidding me he let him live
and then he shot him what that's crazy
it came back around ah
oh this is my favorite part when the guy
stabs him when he's laying right over
him looks them right in the eye
oh dude imagine saying that yeah wait a
minute is that vin diesel
that's the guy from fast and furious who
are here he comes
just a minute mum
no mama just watch and save him private
ryan oh that guy's looking for his arm
isn't he
um
so yeah dude i think that that's what
you do you save the blasters for when
the parents ain't home because the
parents got to leave the parents got to
leave don't they they do sometimes
well i mean yeah i mean i guess if
they're old which they probably are
because he's not it's not like he's you
know he's i mean he's obviously at least
in his late 20s they're below 75 based
on the way he looks so so but that when
they get older and older the parents
stay there but the good thing about that
is they lose their hearing so they lose
their hearing and then blast away but
also
you're an adult
so
you deserve you reserve the right to
participate in blastage whenever you
want here's the other here's the other
thing too you cannot get kicked out
because you're already moving anyway so
you can pretty much do what you want
right and if they say we don't want you
to be blasting in here we don't care if
you're listening to [ __ ] saving
private ryan it's absolutely manzo and
then they'll be like well mom guess what
we're moving to australia anyway come on
partner let's go back in yeah let's
watch [ __ ] whatever that movie is
with paul rudd and tom hanks what's that
the [ __ ] uh
the one that came out the spy one that
came out recently bridge of spies
maybe yeah there's tom yeah
tom hank you know hank is in it tom
hanks
cause only one of them isn't it tom
hanks not all the tom hanks so um all
right cool all right yeah that's okay
cool we got it we figured it out thank
you
here we go
what's up matt what's up chris jack
coming from chicago
got a question for you
so i've been seeing this guy i'm a gay
baby and i've been seeing this guy and
we've been on like five or six dates we
always have fun on the date he's dope i
want to see where it goes yeah but he's
starting to become a bit of an excessive
texture okay i'm getting a text right
when i wake up i'm getting a text at 11
am i'm getting a text at 2 p.m 5 p.m and
it's like
i work full-time i kind of got to stay
focused during the day and also i just
like want to not talk sometimes
so how do i break it to him that
i like him but you know i i can't be
doing this all day texting let me know
i know how to do it i know how to do it
just say you don't even need to say that
say uh
sometimes
i can't text
even if i want to i'm at work i don't
see the text or i have to read it and
then respond later so you can be like
you can make you can frame it like you
don't mind the barrage of texts
but you you you are letting him know
he won't be able to respond all the time
so you're not making it personal to him
you're making it about you and how often
you're available to text back i have a i
have a great oh boy
no it's not if i ever had a good idea a
lot of times we do silly [ __ ] but this
is for real bro i think i have a good
idea you're known as a guy who gives a
good advice whatever quote unquote vomit
but like wow so rude
put your red receipt
read read read read receipts whatever it
is read receipts put your red receipts
on for him
okay this way he knows when you see the
text okay and tell him listen i can't
always respond
you know you text a bunch if that's your
thing i'm not always going to be
responding because i have to work right
and i'm obviously the [ __ ] you know
you're acting like a girl i know you're
a guy but you're acting like a girl
right but don't say that
okay but
but
i'm gonna put my red receipts on so you
know when i get the res that this is out
of respect you know i got it i saw it
and i will respond when i can
putting on the red receipts is going to
change the dynamic oh i don't understand
because the guy's going to [ __ ] see
that he sent it and that he read it and
he's going to get used to the fact that
the guy doesn't respond as soon as he
sees it and then he's going to re
because dude dude i mean i respond to
people sometimes [ __ ] eight hours
later oh dude i'm so bad i will
sometimes just not respond until they
text me again and i'll be like oh right
you texted me before like dude i'm so
bad at it
also you could just have a conversation
and be like dude the greatest thing
about being gay is we don't have to deal
with [ __ ] like this nobody's a straight
girl guys don't give a [ __ ] dude i'm
gonna i'm a dude and guess what we're
we're we're chilling we're gay we're
missing out by you texting me all the
time
we're missing out on the best part of
being gay not having to deal with the
woman yeah well right but super sounds
really messed up in the negative in the
negative way
women are great obviously okay but in
the negative ways that women are and a
lot of [ __ ] men are negative in a lot
of ways
but we're not talking about that right
now we're talking about right now you're
acting like a woman right the best part
of being gay is i don't have to talk
when i don't want to dude we can just
chill okay and [ __ ] hang out watch
saving private ryan or whatever it is
and not have to talk to each other bro
but what if this is a guy who
leans more to the feminine in that way
obviously there are many men like that
yeah but then he's got to find another
dude that's going to be more expensive
that's not a [ __ ] deal breaker is it
texting a lot just be like look i don't
text that much
that's it okay if the other guy deals
with it nice then good well that's what
i'm saying then it's on him
that's a weird problem to have if you're
gonna be gay you need to be all the way
gay and still be a dude and also [ __ ]
be able to be like look dude we're we're
bros at the end of the day we're bros
now you know what i mean whether you're
top or bottom it's all good maybe
sometimes on top sometimes on bottom
maybe we mix it up whatever it is i
don't know what your kink is but one of
the [ __ ] things that's a pro about
being [ __ ] gay is that we're dudes
and we don't have to [ __ ] do this
[ __ ] all the time right yeah you don't
have to do this [ __ ] all the time yeah
yeah okay
well there you have it yes got out of
that one who's a handsome guy a guy yeah
it was a good looking guy i'm sure the
[ __ ] boyfriend is a good looking too
okay what do you guys think about um
do not disturb
things in general on the iphone thing i
have almost every single person i know
on do not disturb yeah but that's still
i never get alerts on my phone anymore i
have to look at my phone to get a text
that's good you know uh but no that
still doesn't
save i mean he could say i have my [ __ ]
on do not disturb i think he should let
the guy know all the reasons why
he doesn't not that he doesn't want a
text he should frame it as
he doesn't see text he's not good at
texting it takes him a while to get back
to certain texts
all that [ __ ] everything's short of you
text too much and stop it you know i i
also uh sometimes get like i'll wake up
in the morning i'll get eight texts and
i'll check them and i because i'm hot
hazy and foggy yeah i don't even
remember that totally you do that too
yeah absolutely i always have more than
eight because i'm really popular but
yeah no but i have eight because i only
sleep for like an hour i listen for an
hour i'll wake up i have eight but if i
see for eight hours i'll have almost
250. yeah i'll have like i have like two
1600 i think it's like three hundred ten
hundred i think i have about three or
eight i'm honestly about four hundred
i've had there's been a bunch of times
where i've had a thousand i'll have like
two
two or three thousand
all right so
all right next one dude
[Music]
you want to read it
okay i mean i mean you know i robots i
female 21 oh okay i f21 and my boyfriend
m21 hi female 21 years old and my
boyfriend mel 21 years old currently
lived together and have been together
for about four months to explain why we
are living together at the four month
mark quick we started out as roommates
but then started dating oh my god oh wow
okay i have to say my boyfriend has
never been good at
pet names oh boy some early ones were
little stubster little stubster that
sounds like a [ __ ] honestly that
sounds like a sitcom in the 80s with one
of those short black dudes that never
grew up and sour meat
dude this guy needs to do this
oh hi sour meat that's just like a
straight up boner killer why would you
do that oh man sour meat one of my
nicknames for him in comparison is
little bird that's a cute one so sweet
yeah yeah little bird hi sour meat hey
little bird hey [ __ ] [ __ ] mcgillicuddy
anyway about two weeks ago he starts
calling me tony pizza
tony peter
are you dating what what this doesn't
mean
this doesn't even make sense and he uses
it more often than my actions this guy
is an alien masquerading as a human
being he is obsessed pet names like tony
pizza and sour meat and also little
substance
honestly bothers me that he can't even
plan
to find a somewhat nice nickname for me
i have had a couple of conversations
with him about it but he says he just
can't think of anything better
what do i do is this going to become a
bigger problem or should i even address
it i hate being tony pizza
i would
hate being tony pizza too you know what
the best i would love being tony pizza
dude are you [ __ ] your name was
totally pizza was calling you tony pizza
as a pet name come on i don't know man
it's kind of weird your name was tony
pizza that's cool but this is a pet name
like a term of endearment from your
loved one no dude no no if you're having
sex with someone and all of a sudden
you're like yo i'm tony pizza right you
can say it about yourself but imagine a
woman saying it to you hey come on down
to tony pizza's jeweler okay jewelers
hey come on down at the by the way you
know the best part about this is he used
to eat as a kid tony's pizza remember
tony's pizza yeah he definitely has that
that's why he's getting that and he's
calling her tony pizza because when he
was a kid he would eat tony's an
association with it yeah yeah what i
think is you absolutely have to address
it you have to say look
the names you have for me are [ __ ]
disgusting and they make me feel
disgusting and you're stupid if you
think they're good wow you can't think
of anything else other than
little stubster
such a [ __ ] [ __ ] sad meat or
whatever sour meat sad meat would be
better yeah sad meat what's happening
would be way better sour meat is only
disgusting dude
this guy sucks dude break up with him i
want to know who this guy is very badly
also he's 21. to be [ __ ] 21 and have
that this guy's creative is [ __ ]
honestly to be able to do that i mean
dude
little little stubster is one thing
that's just sour meat is incredible but
tony pizza is the most unreal [ __ ]
name to the remember we had the [ __ ]
uh
remember when you had this stupid what
do you play the [ __ ] baseball the
yeah stupid [ __ ] no the what
the
on virtual baseball what the [ __ ] do you
call it oh oh oh oh what do you do it
every day you do it every day
fantasy baseball okay yeah
uh tommy sandwich thomas i don't know
where thomas is because i said because i
was saying like kevin bacon is like
basically that's the word his last name
is bacon just a spicy food pizza yeah
so wait hold on
first let's go in order little stubster
is [ __ ] rude no straight up
but
straight up it's ruth there is an
argument that little stubster is
kind of cute in a way
there's an argument it's like calling
somebody a little chubby boy
little chubby that's kind of cute no
dude okay anyway
sour meat is just like
yeah sour meat is like a bad guy in the
cr in the [ __ ] comic books tracy the
spawn i said okay so i was saying it's
something a little slightly better but
it's okay that's okay so then you know
it's sour
vacuum tony pizza is fine but as as a
pet name for your [ __ ] girl tony
pizza dude it would also be dick these
are all dick trees honestly these are
all dick crazy yeah yeah little stubster
[ __ ]
a sour meat and tony pizza dude this guy
is honestly just a big dick tracy fan
yes and we just figured it out yeah this
is unbelievable just bring it up to him
and be like yo what the [ __ ] is with
your naming capabilities if we ever have
kids and you get an am what are you
gonna name them dude right
astronaut cosmonaut right right like you
got to [ __ ] figure out the the the
right this is a little alarming dude i
agree call me little teddy bear call me
[ __ ] you know what i mean just only
starship troopers call me anything but
[ __ ] i love how he says he just can't
think of anything better go online you
[ __ ] idiot he's just lazy dude we
don't hope he does it during sex break
up with him i hope he does it during sex
i'm i firmly believe break up with him
no yes dude this guy's a creative guy
this is the kind of guy who will sell a
company for a billion dollars in [ __ ]
[ __ ] in 15 ted bundy was creative
dude call him ted bundy call him
yeah actually you know what yeah
that's it throw it back in his face by
calling him really shitty stuff
tit-for-tat like smelly armpit yeah
small dick hey small dick hey small dick
johnson small dick mcgee
smelly armpit johnson wow yeah hey
stinky [ __ ] stinky [ __ ] all
right guys this podcast's gone off the
rails what's the next one
hey christopher and matthew my name is
adelaide and i am a huge fan so i want
to start with that
um but i wanted to ask you guys a
question
so i'm super mixed
always have been always will be and i've
always had a problem with how people
address that though oh like i've
consistently walked up to and asked
things like
what are you or where are you from or
what are you mixed with so i guess my
question is like how do you respond to
people like that
this is a daily thing for me so
any help appreciated okay have a good
one i think for me whenever somebody
asks me where i'm from or like what my
ethnicity is i honestly find those
conversations so boring that i think
maybe a good thing to do is just say
like like
ask do do what happens there hey what's
going on where are you
what are you you're boring
but okay you're boring me oh
wow yeah are you black or white boring
me oh and then i'll stop
yeah that's really i mean it'll stop
um i have to be i have to be honest so
when i saw her i thought wow she's
like the most fifty percent white and
fifty percent black like remember that
seinfeld episode where they couldn't
tell if the person was white or black no
actually and they were like we don't
know what it is that's what
and george is like i can't tell [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] he is you know this is
exactly what's every episode you know
she can't yeah yeah but she yeah and she
even she's not doing herself any favors
by having a the blunt the hair blonde
but that's okay though do what you want
live your truth but what is your truth
but that's what people want and also if
you don't deserve to know that whoops
right okay but they don't deserve to
know that unless she i don't know is it
a weird thing to be like where are you
from it's annoying it is annoying
because you know here's the thing when i
saw her i thought wow i wonder what she
is oh you did yeah i did yeah did you no
it was the first thing i thought but
then i immediately thought she probably
gets that all the time yeah so i would
not ask her that at least from jump yeah
you never ask somebody that
here's the deal you never ask somebody
something that is clear they get asked
it all the time right like for me like
dude how big must your dick be no that
doesn't mean they do do that though that
doesn't happen they go like this
yeah they say like dude does it weigh
down on your test they go does it weigh
down on your testicles and then the
first time when i was like what do you
mean oh my and they said because you're
obviously and i go okay yeah right that
yeah most conversations how they start
for me i'm gonna
i don't think that happens but it's okay
you're not anything that get the
anything that anything that's obviously
asked of someone a lot is going to annoy
them if you also ask it
curb your [ __ ] curiosity because we
all know that what the truth is people
ask because they want to fill the
[ __ ] air they don't actually have
small [ __ ] really the worst they're not
going to remember when they walk away so
why ask the annoying thing
just don't [ __ ] ask that in general
people stop asking people that it's so
boring and annoying hmm who's excited to
be like
yes somebody asked me about my info
white black and a little bit mexican
then you got to tell them like it's not
nobody likes that you guys say you they
say what is where what are you fro what
are they what's the question she gets
what are you and then she says what's
your favorite movie and they say oh uh
and they answer and they say good now
we're both boring spinning out that's
good um now we're both born we need to
match your boringness
it's a good move and so uh i think that
uh
yeah i don't know man but yeah i think
that it's just really good it's one of
you know what dude it is it's one of
those things you got to just [ __ ]
sometimes charge to the game though
right
meaning well like it's just like the
your thing it's gonna suck man it's just
one of those things you got to charge it
to the game that's gay yeah or i guess
you could answer and just be so clearly
like annoyed about it just like that
yeah exactly dude exactly what i was
mixed i'm white and black my mom and my
my mom was white my dad was black
because it's never obviously the other
way around but yeah
and then say you're happy now like that
are you are you happy now yeah you know
i think that uh yeah i mean that's what
i do when people are like dude is the
top you know does that is the top of
your penis no no but they're like is it
often raw and red and i'm like why in
the first beginning i was like why and
they're like because when you walk
forward obviously the top of it drags on
the ground behind you and i go
no it's not actually i you know i make
sure that i [ __ ] scoop it around my
leg and i tie mine up so they're not
facing out right and so they're like wow
and then i go yeah and so that's how i
that's how i combat that question but i
still go like this when they go like
this
is your
the top of your and i go
right i wrap it and i cut them off as i
wrap it around my leg and then go oh
okay okay okay okay that's all good man
that's just not what they were gonna ask
you when [ __ ] there's
i wrapped my dick around my leg i was
gonna ask if the top floor is 10 or 11.
all right cool
now a word from our sponsor better help
how well would you take care of your car
if you had to keep the same one your
entire life
that's how our brains work so why don't
we treat them that way
therapy is something that's near and
dear to my heart i mean this show is an
advice show but therapy is the real deal
when you have serious issues serious
problems anything in your life that
comes up you want to talk to a therapist
i can't recommend therapy more to anyone
and everyone everyone should be in
therapy and i've even tried better help
and better help is amazing it's great
because it's better help is online
therapy that offers video phone and even
live chat only therapy sessions so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't even want to it's just all for
you it's focused on you it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy which
is great and the cool thing is you can
be matched with a therapist in under 48
hours which is really lightning quick
especially it's hard to find one you
know you a lot of the time when you're
on your own and not online and not using
better help so that's why betterhelp is
really great yeah otherwise you get on a
waitlist it just takes forever and ever
this is the way to go better help our
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com lifeline that's better
h-e-l-p-com
lifeline so go on over there and give it
a shot better help is uh is a really
great uh really great thing to do here
we go let's do it
and chris wow what's up my babies going
skydiving my girlfriend and i i mean
what the [ __ ] is he wearing my wife now
he's a straight jacket couldn't get his
belt out together for four years
look at his headphones dude only one of
them is on
it would be like his [ __ ] glasses are
like this
hey what's up one legging is shorts hey
what's up man uh my question is kind of
obvious how do you wear stuff
[Laughter]
all right go ahead everyday
i'm sure that's how every relationship
goes his hat isn't even on right now
like once a month
he's talking about having sex yeah
i know that's irregular for
any young
couple
but
it seems to me like she's falling out of
sexual attraction i'm so comfortable
talking about anything
this guy yeah i want to know what you
might think
of
what that
reason is the most comfortable kite
reason for that right all right about
anything oh who's this [ __ ] this guy's
the shirt oh my god i've never seen
somebody more comfortable in his own
skin talking about anything because he's
talking about his sex life and he's on
like they were they were like his friend
was like do you want to blur your face
out and he literally goes like this
why would i do that yeah
right yeah but the thing is that when
she's gonna rest your clothes what do
you mean i'm putting on half of it
it's definitely not that she's not
attractive anymore because the way you
are being dude
literally you could be a [ __ ] one
yeah this guy
cleans it up yeah if you're if you're
that confident it just doesn't matter
what you look like uh but let's say that
you need to know the answer
i think they're just like most things
there's a way to ask
that without being like hey why don't
you want to [ __ ] anymore for instance
right
how do you how like
is there something i could be doing more
like i feel like we used to have more
sex is our passion dwindling if it is
what can i do
like
recharge it like what what what are the
things that you need uh and then once
the conversation's going
your partner will eventually tell you
the deal you know like if you make it a
safe place for her to say whatever she
will tell you the thing if they're
look it's totally possible that it's
nothing her sex drive just has waned
there's nothing to do with him yeah but
like if it if there is an underlying
reason
that uh she's sort of nervous about
sharing i think opening up a space like
that
communication that kind of [ __ ]
she'll be able to have a safe zone to
say that [ __ ]
oh man that's incredible i just can't
believe how i honestly think that guy's
the most comfortable guy i've ever seen
in my life he's comfortable
he would just walk up to his wife and
just be like
[Music]
in front of her family what are we doing
doinking why don't we donk why don't we
have sex here here's the deal i don't
know if you guys know
but uh
we don't have sex much wow
um hey mom at thanksgiving hey hey her
mom and hey her dad yeah anyway can you
pass the gravy
maybe once a month it's all good but
past me half the gravy i'll only use
half of it
what what what is your advice dude
you
i mean
here's
i have advice which is similar to yours
but i also think that this kind of stuff
just comes and goes in waves like i have
a lot of old friends that have been
married for a long time and they're like
yes sometimes you go a year and it's not
good sometimes you go two years is not
good sometimes you go a month it's not
good but then you go and you have like a
string of [ __ ] months or a year
that's just great it's true you know
it's part of commitment it's part of
being with somebody it's part of uh
marriage you know and uh and i just
think that right now you're in one of
those moments you know sometimes the
shirt's half on you know as they say as
john lennon said john lennon said
sometimes your hat's tipping off the
back of your head and you're only
wearing one headphone yeah the
headphones thing was what did it also
what was around your chest also where
was he was like i think he fell out of a
plane hit the ground and immediately
started recording the video dude
[Music]
so my wife
it's all good but we don't have sex we
have it like once
so basically what do i do
and then he went and then he stopped
recording and he just goes
oh my god i didn't realize how much pain
he's right he broke his back you know uh
so wait i think the one other thing i
want to say before we move on is i don't
think you should be assuming
don't exactly bringing up with her
that it's some kind of attraction level
thing it's not
good i'm telling you right now dude
okay but
but it's not a good assumption to make
no it's not bad it's not good to make
any assumptions yes but that's just that
one is specifically bad because it'll
[ __ ] change the way you're directing
it and it'll make him resentful and be
[ __ ] weird and that'll make it even
worse whatever's going on yeah
so um yeah don't assume
anything honestly ever yeah really yeah
okay all right cool
next one next one next one hey guys um
my question is
is it
ever okay to move on
after your spouse passes away my fiance
passed away in december
and i get a lot of people telling me
that like they hope that i move on and i
find somebody else someday
um but like i just don't feel
like that's appropriate um like his
family doesn't get to replace him so
like what gives me the right so
i'm just wondering like what your take
would be and if you were in my shoes
what would you do oh and if you are
going to move on
what's the appropriate length of time
before you move on
thanks
here's the deal first of all that's
terrible and i'm so [ __ ] sorry that
that happened that's
unimaginable
and
just my heart goes out to you and and
his family um as far as moving on
i don't think that you should put a hard
and fast rule on yourself about that if
you don't feel like doing it then you
definitely should not if you start
feeling like doing it you gotta lose
this idea that it's inappropriate it's
not inappropriate unless you feel that
deeply on the inside but don't there's
no rule that says
you know it's inappropriate until
x amount of months or whatever years uh
that's just not
it's not a fair way to treat yourself
uh but and i also think that the thing
that you mentioned about his family
doesn't get to replace him but
but you know and so neither should you i
don't really agree with that because i
don't think that you know when you have
a child
um
do you have either that just that child
or more children and you're right they
are irreplaceable as that individual
child but people
all the time get married and divorced
have long relationships that end
amicably
often and so i think that you should
give yourself the leeway
the the bottom line is sadly he is gone
and you are still here and i think
because of that
and i think he would say this too and i
i mean i'm assuming even his family
would agree
you
deserve to be happy in this one life
that you have so i don't think you
should put some hard and fast rules on
yourself for you're not allowed to you
shouldn't do it it would be a bad thing
to do it's not a bad thing to do if you
don't feel like doing it then don't but
don't make yourself
not do it because of some rule that you
perceive to be some kind of moral code
it's don't put that on yourself it's
enough that your fiance has passed away
that is plenty don't add to your
troubles yeah don't i mean
she's asking when is an appropriate
amount of time there is no appropriate
amount of time it's whenever you feel
like i think that like your parents or
hurt their parents was it their parents
or i think she's talking about the
history yeah
yeah i mean it's tough man i mean i i
don't know what the right
uh answer for it is i don't imagine it's
easy at all i'm really sorry that this
happened
um
i think it's just
a slow process that's very you know
you take your steps as you can and
hopefully it feels okay when it does and
if it does then that's a some sort of a
blessing in your life i you know
it's i don't think there's any real
answer here you're right that there's no
right answer but there i believe that
there is a wrong answer and that wrong
answer would be that you can absolutely
never move on that is not fair to
yourself and again you're you remain you
have a life and you need to live it that
doesn't mean get back out there it's
time to move on that is [ __ ] and
anyone that's sitting there telling you
you have to move on come on get pull
pull yourself up by the bootstraps get
yourself out of bed that's horseshit if
it takes you six months 18 months
[ __ ] five years it doesn't matter but
at some point if you start to feel like
getting back out there and maybe meeting
someone do it absolutely just do it do
not hold yourself back because of some
perceived morality that you feel like
you need to put up put on yourself that
that's not
that's not fair to you and also just
objectively it's not right it's not
right
i get that you would feel that way
though it's it's a heartbreak and you're
probably emotionally just [ __ ]
crushed and it's gonna take a minute but
don't add to the to the troubles yeah
that makes me sad i don't um
i don't have much to add to that i mean
i don't even know what i would do i
think it's just um and i think you know
sorry but his family is one thing but
they're going through a different thing
i'm sure there are online communities of
people who have lost romantic intimate
partners uh suddenly
or not so suddenly it doesn't matter but
before their time you know you're still
very young
uh so i think that give yourself all the
time that you need but also maybe seek
out people who have gone through similar
things i know just from firsthand
experience that
obviously this hasn't happened to me but
other things that have been traumatic
finding other people who have gone
through the exact same thing who
understand it in their version but
understand it in a broad way
maybe hearing their stories
or even just like reading about their
stories you don't even need to talk to
these people if you don't want to uh
could really sort of help a lot i think
yeah you know yeah my heart goes out to
you man i'm i'm i'm sorry to hear that
it's brutal but we love you and uh
take care of yourself first and foremost
matt you are much better looking than
chris okay well i've been running for
years he looks like his way of getting
rid of stress and anxiety and like
decompressing and like it's my outlet
that's what i do there's this family in
my neighborhood that um when they see me
running they turn the little
five-year-old loose and a little
five-year-old tries to come out of the
street and play tag with me when i'm
doing my sprints and like i'm not a
babysitter like this has been going on
for months i started off really nice
you know i'd wait for the kid to get
tired and try and finish up my run later
but like the kid is
like it sticks around for longer and
longer now i've let the charade go on
for so long i tried to be too nice about
it and now i'm at this point where i
don't know them i can't set that
boundary because i don't know them but
this kid comes out in the middle of
street and i'm babysitting while i'm
working out like it's so stupid get out
of my stupid face do i need to perform
like spin moves or something like do i
need to throw like hot flaming toilet
paper balls in there yes i don't know i
was gonna say that i was gonna say that
that'd be weird if yeah that would be
weird if you were gonna say that i mean
he's running by and they do this he said
he's got a workout routine that involves
him running back and forth past his
neighbor's house and when the
five-year-old sees
this happen yeah he is loosed upon this
poor guy put him in the [ __ ] work get
him uh you know what i mean working out
have him go into your house and take
care of like do the dishes make your bed
whatever the [ __ ] like put this
[ __ ] away yeah it's so that's so
annoying it's annoying yeah i mean like
i you know it's it's not it's it's one
of those things that's annoying but it's
like cute the kid's cute so you're like
oh [ __ ] but the parents are annoying
right yeah but are they watching him
because if they're not watching him then
you should have a conversation with the
parents and be like yo i'm trying to
work out and i don't know if this kid
you know i'm gonna run into your kid i
don't want your kid to get hurt i'm
working out you know i push [ __ ]
crazy weight you know make up whatever
the [ __ ] he said the parents are setting
the kid loose yes exactly so you got to
go over there and knock on the door and
say hey look
your kid's fine i don't mind him being
out here when i am but like obviously
it's a [ __ ] free country do what you
want but
you can't leave him with me
i don't give a [ __ ] about your kid right
and i just want you to let you know yeah
yeah i'm not gonna watch him yeah so if
anything bad happens guess whose fault
it is right only yours i'm not watching
you i'm not watching a kid i got weights
that i'm moving around i don't want your
kid to get in any any sort of pain so
you got to keep an eye on your kid if if
i'm running by your house on the street
it's not your property right i'm [ __ ]
you know what i mean and keep running
don't stop just keep running
they're doing the thing where they're
just like ah yeah he'll watch him you
know what i mean if i'm doing some [ __ ]
inside or yeah you know the kid he's not
always gonna let the kid get taken no
right well i think that's the thing you
need to be clear if your kid gets
kidnapped i'm just gonna let it happen
i'm not doing anything i'm not watching
this kid it's not my responsibility i
don't know where you got the [ __ ]
idea in your head that it is but this is
not my [ __ ] thing
i'm just letting you know
i'm not watching your kid and
and i'm not just not watching because
i'm oblivious i'm purposely not watching
your kid i don't want to do that i'm
working out not [ __ ] babysitting
like dude there i understand he doesn't
want to set the boundary because he
doesn't know him but they're being crazy
rude and irresponsible well it's just
they're probably just got their head up
their ass you got to be like dude i
don't know if you've heard about the
zone but when i work out i get in that
and i can't [ __ ] see [ __ ] around that
so if your five-year-old's running
around playing with my weights he's
gonna get hurt and i'm in the zone dude
so it's not gonna be my fault you don't
want your kid to die because i'm in the
zone it's about him like running off
getting into some other thing right
right you don't want your kid to get
taken because i'm in the zone yeah okay
but just blame it on the zone
i'm just saying dude the [ __ ] you
know i don't know you know the husband's
probably out of shape she'd be like your
husband's out of shape he's probably
never or very rarely been in the zone he
probably hasn't been in the zone since
high school i live in that zone right
when i'm out here with the zone yeah i
live in that when i'm running back and
forth that's exactly where i am and
guess who's not in the zone anyone else
for your kid definitely but anyone else
so familiarize the parents with the
zones step one first and then be like
watch your kid let them know that you
inhabit the zone step three let them
know their kid will never inhabit the
zone and therefore
this is not gonna work i mean the kid
might be in the zone but he's not gonna
be in my zone he's gonna grow up and be
in his own zone well he'll grow up
eventually being his own zone but
nobody's in any zone at five right there
you go except like the [ __ ] of your
pants educate them about the zone the
[ __ ] your pants is on right that zone is
something that kids do but educate them
about the zone and then also say look
you know
that's not gonna all right okay good
cool
so basically uh this one's another
written one so basically a good buddy of
mine is seriously dating a friend of my
sister hold on a second a good buddy of
mine is seriously dating
a friend
i can't ever do this hold on so a good
buddy of his
is seriously dating a friend of mine
sister i was like i get it it's like
steven vecchio
wow i mean i'm taking them all the way
back i'm dating laura in the vecchio
current friends but okay uh her and my
sister are part of my guy's friend group
of six dudes i recently found out that
his girl went on a date with someone
else behind his back because her dad
forced her to that's in quotes by the
way i only found out from my sister and
i swore i wouldn't tell him if i tell
him i essentially ruined my sister and
hurts friendship because my sister
wasn't supposed to tell anyone and then
there's beef with me and my sister and
her and my sister and the holy christ
the whole tris group is gonna be
affected okay that's not a word oh but
all i know is if i wrote a group
triangle i mean i don't know whatever
the [ __ ] but all i know is if i were in
his position i would need to know this
makes me so mad because my guy has no
idea and plans to marry her
i want to tell him so bad but i don't
know what the right thing to do is
uh i think you have to
do of i need you need to get to her
somehow whether that's through yourself
or you don't want to blow up your
sister's spot and you want to maybe make
your sister say to her friend
hey this guy's really serious about you
and we're all like a really tight friend
group i'm not gonna say anything but i
think you need to like he's gonna try to
he's gonna keep pursuing this and wants
to turn into something lifelong like
he needs to know and i think that
you need to
talk to him about this tell him about
this
give her the option to it's never good
to be like hey dude
your [ __ ] girl's cheating on you you
want to talk to the girl first and give
her the chance to do it well they they
went out they hung out because the dad
wanted them to whatever that's all about
that's in quotes i think he's implying
that he doesn't believe it oh okay i got
you okay and then
that that's all that happened
she went on a [ __ ] date with someone
else is what happened yeah how old are
they that's a that definitely
you know i mean it sounds like they're
like [ __ ] 19. it sounds yeah they
sound like they're in their late teens
honestly i agree so like he wants to
marry her but also she's not gonna marry
her anyway you know what i mean just let
it play out i think maybe start talking
[ __ ] about her too to him to your friend
wait who the guy that's writing should
talk to his friend and be like ah dude i
know you're gonna marry her i don't know
if that's a good idea
you know
yeah maybe i don't know i mean you don't
that is a bad spot yeah but you run the
risk of saying hey look dude you know uh
if you involve yourself you will run the
risk of ruining your friendship with the
dude
the guy could be like [ __ ] off this and
that you know what i mean you don't need
to be too forceful about it i know i
don't know i know obviously they'll be
forceful no matter what but like you run
the risk of getting involved and then
having it backfire on you
it could totally be the kind of thing
where it's just like
i mean dude if it was
uh a hangout
and that was just that
oh wait i got the advice okay but i got
the advice the advice
i got the advice the advice is this
tell your sister
you need to talk to your friend and
confront her about this and tell her
that she needs to tell my friend who
she's dating that she dated someone else
behind his back hold on hold on hold on
tell your sister there's so many i can't
do this dude
see that's pissing me off because it's
it's so hard
okay do it again say it
i
i'm suggesting that this guy talked to
his sister okay who's friends with the
cheater
okay
and the cheater told
his sister that he can't that she can't
tell anybody
and she told the guy that wrote in okay
so he's not supposed to know
so he needs to talk to the sister and
say talk
you need to talk to your friend or else
i'm going to
and that can't happen because the sister
is going to say no you can't do that and
you're going to say well you better then
because i'm going to if you don't do it
so you're forcing the sister to confront
her friend who's the cheater about
cheating okay and then so you don't get
involved exactly i see what you're
saying and then the threat over her head
is jesus christ i'll [ __ ]
i'll do it if you don't and that'll make
you look bad to your friend
okay so then
she's gotta [ __ ]
talk to her friend about cheating and
then she's gotta confront her
and then so that he can be confronted
[ __ ]
it's too hard it's not hard you [ __ ]
me up i didn't [ __ ] you up i wasn't
saying anything you looked confused i i
okay well i agree with you i guess okay
good i don't know who's who dude there's
too many friends and [ __ ] let me just
finish it like this then have the person
write in god this other person writing
in a guy who wrote in
talk to your sister and say look if you
don't confront your friend about this
i'm going to
your sister will be like no no you can't
and then you can be like yeah of course
i can but you have to i get that and if
you don't i'm gonna
and then so therefore
you wipe your hands clean you don't your
sister's friend doesn't need to know she
told you
it stays among them in her friend's mind
okay and then she can with that
information
go to her boyfriend and be like because
you gotta put the pressure on and box
them all in right
so he can have this domino effect by
doing that and ensure that the [ __ ]
cheating friend confronts his cheated on
friend
with the truth right yeah okay okay go
go make a disclaimer dude if you're not
the guy don't write in
what's happening here no i get i totally
get it it's a guy i i know somebody who
actually met somebody once but he's in a
danny's diner and the waitress was
telling him
dude this is like if
my don't do back in new jersey mike
lavecchio said the thing about i don't i
[ __ ] haven't talked to them in 20
years i don't remember who was friends
with who i'm pissed off at you it's all
right i don't get it there's too many i
can't do this anytime someone says this
is my brother's [ __ ] friend's
sister's mother i don't know i'm done
well then i need to be talking
maybe maybe i gotta [ __ ] need ginkgo
biloba but the second somebody says to
me
hey dude this is my friend's boom i'm
out if it's not your friend or your
sister if it's your sister's friend okay
but if it's your sister's friend's then
boom i'm done any more than two i'm done
you're a straight up video you're a
straight-up idiot i try hard that's why
i can't follow shows like [ __ ] game
of thrones congrats on being a
straight-up idiot it's all good well i'm
sorry good next one i'm sorry i can't
give you advice on that one because i
don't know advice you did okay okay
great okay next
hey chris and matt what's up um my name
is tori
and i have a little
problem i need some help with
somebody yeah but i need some advice
about how to approach this guy yeah i
have a crush on it yeah
and i mean i have a crush on him for no
reason other than physical and i see
that's how that works
the gym
and it's
hard for me to think of a way to dodge
anyone in the gym because no one wants
to talk to him yeah of course or i also
see him like in the elevator he'll be
getting off and i'll be getting on
and i always feel like it's when i'm
looking my worst feeling my horse but
just to like rip the bandaid off and be
you know say hey or something i just
can't think of what to do to break the
ice so i need your help
um
it would be so appreciated
love the show thanks so
much well you see him in two different
places the elevator to the gym and the
gym though yeah
so kind of the same kind of the same
place yeah you're kind of [ __ ] making
it like a student
elevator is way better than the gym yeah
that's confusing right yeah yeah but but
i don't know man i mean the second you
try to think about what you're going to
say you're kind of already [ __ ]
honestly here's what you say
uh it's easier for a woman toward a man
at the gym because the the thing that is
the biggest no-no ever
at the time it's just not gonna yeah
the other way around is still kind of
dicey but it's not nearly as [ __ ] bad
yeah but anyway uh i think in the
elevator next time you see him
make like a f she's cute and she's being
cute and laughing at herself
take that same exact vibe and say
oh this is so weird but you know i
didn't want to do it inside the gym but
we always run into each other here and i
thought why not just tell you like i
actually have like a crush on you and
it's silly but i just want to let you
know and like maybe you want to hang out
sometime that would be
no
that's like [ __ ] old-fashioned [ __ ]
just be like yo what's up how you doing
my friends and i are going to be
somewhere why don't you come meet up
with you and your friends don't like it
why though playing it too cool
she got to be honest and earnest her
vibe is the honest and earnest cute
thing yeah i know but she doesn't seem
to be alluring and [ __ ] like she can't
be like i have a crush on you that's
like because the guy's gonna be like got
this you need to be the guy you need to
make the guy be like oh that was cool
that was that was an interesting
situation huh what's that girl all about
you can't play all your cards bro
[Music]
you can't play all your cards
uh i think what i said is great if you
want to take a bigger chance do what i
said if you want to play it all cool and
[ __ ] do what he said no don't play it
it's not about playing it cool it's
about getting the guy to be intrigued
with it all right maybe don't say crush
but be like oh man like i feel like we
run into each other a lot of times on
the elevator uh i feel like
maybe
i don't know yeah
be cute and [ __ ] don't be like cool yeah
no i'm not saying be cool but be like yo
um hey i uh
uh
i see you here all the time you you
should get some friends i'm meeting my
friends because you don't even know if
you like the guy yet you just have a
crush she likes him
but you don't know though the guy could
be like [ __ ] terrible and at which
point she could hang out with him for an
hour and leave and i know
if you meet up with friends if you say
my friends are coming you should come
and then you know if he shows up he's
kind of interested
i think that that's a move okay well you
just say look my friends are hanging out
with this at this place come with your
friends if you want if he shows up then
you know he's interested if he doesn't
then maybe he still is but still you
know that you've got the gym and you
could see him all the time yeah i think
yeah i mean i think we disagree on this
one that's not the worst thing you think
i should say hey i notice you you have
you know i think you're cool we should
hang out sometimes oh she should be like
oh i'm kind of like embarrassed and i
would never do this at the gym but like
we run into each other time and i don't
know i just i thought you were cute
maybe we could like go get a coffee
sometimes you would like that oh yeah
dude just straight honesty and not
creepiness always the best if she can
pull that off yeah but that's very hard
to pull off but if she all she needs to
do is take the vibe that she took to
that video okay that's it
is she saying the gym is in their
building i don't know i'm confused by
that too i thought
i thought maybe she meant the elevator
is just at the gym but i didn't think i
could sing the elevator at their
building
building and she sees them at the gym oh
then you could say and honestly the best
thing is that the gym in the building
the gym in the elevator and my apartment
are the same place if we end up hitting
it off we could live still live here and
we could always be together yeah well
that now that would be bad that's
something that you like to say probably
that would be a robot all right cool
well look that's what we have for this
uh this this today um if you have a
question then go to watchlifeline.com
and also you can get the lifeline merch
on my website or the other website that
we have for lifeline uh which is what
watch lifeline.com
and get the lifeline merch.com
lifelinemerch.lifelinemerch.com yes so
that's that and uh and that's it and
leave your comments on what you think
the advices should be in the in the
comment and then subscribe to super cold
studios we really appreciate it and
subscribe to also the clip channel that
would be great we got super cool clips
thank you very much you guys you rock
yeah
we love you yeah
hello
[Music]